i've seen jenkins bully too he in the
beginning when defunded the police was
becoming popular
jake was smart he was like this is a
stupid slogan and you know 80
of people are against defunding the
police but slowly but surely because his
audience is supposed to be like more on
the left
he started saying listed i'm gonna be
this defund the police guy and now every
time he talks about it
he's like we're in four defund the
police and then it's like a 30-second
explanation
he's for it but then he gives you like
the 45-minute pitch of why that doesn't
actually mean defund the police
he was right the first time defund the
police is a stupid slogan yeah
i wish i would have invented it for the
democrats to use because it's tanking
them across the country but
yeah like so i've seen him get bullied
by his audience so this might be an
issue where he's like
that's questionable but over time it got
he got brow beat by his audience
the most fascinating thing now that i
see with the young turks is janks
insistence that
the alt left exists and what does that
mean
glenn greenwald michael tracy aaron mate
and jimmy dore
the alt left i love it that's not what
alt left means it's not what it ever
meant and it never really caught on
anyway
so it's funny that he tries claiming
that the people who criticize the
establishment and his fake progressive
movement
are alt-right and alt-left it's like
dude maybe you've just lost the plot
because you're chasing the dragon man
you want the ratings you want the clicks
you look at the supercuts of the young
turks over the years
and it's really it's really you can
really see how they've compromised over
and over and over again i saw uh a clip
of them
from they had the new hire and she was
like three days on and he was like what
career you don't have
do you ever see that oh a kim horchata
you kind of and he as you can tell
immediately felt horrible about it but
he was
so chill back then he was so much more
relaxed he's so like
agitated things have like tweaked him
out over the last like six years
i totally get it i do we talked about
this we talked about this the other day
man this is important
i uh you know when i got started in
more actively publicly in politics like
occupy wall street
i i went to occupy wall street because i
saw these videos
of police like it's just dragging a guy
by his foot and it's like his hands
bleeding
but i also knew a bunch of hackers
because i'd been hanging out hacker
spaces in los angeles i knew a bunch of
hackers
you know around the world actually
because i i made some friends got some
connections
these all were on the left all the
hacking community was on the left
anti-establishment
anti-fed anti-intelligence agencies they
were pro-journalists pro-information
pro-free speech
and then something changed a bunch of
these hackers
all of a sudden became authoritarian and
pro-fbi
in fact some of the some of these people
are on were on facebook
cheering for the fbi raid on giuliani
and i commented on the post saying
i'm so glad to see you finally been
de-radicalized that you would now
actively support the fbi and they're
like
well i mean well they're doing the right
thing now
dude these people on the left used to
laugh about the trolling that weave
would do
i can't even say the name of weaves
organization i cannot say some of the
things he's done
one of the most notorious trolls if not
the most notorious troll on the internet
saying the most offensive things a bunch
of people on the left
recognized the right of free speech and
they were edgy
and they were fun and they mocked things
and they made jokes
and you had george carlin and george
carlin would say all of the racial slurs
in the world in his bit
then something started to change over
the past 10 years rapidly and quickly
where for whatever reason the leftists
fell in line so imagine you're gent
yogurt
and you're watching the transformation
of your audience
i gotta be honest i i i the last time i
saw uh
gent we got he yelled at me because he
was losing it before that i was shaking
his hands at vidcon
so only like probably three three and a
half years ago maybe
talking to him about ad rates and
youtube and then he started
to lose it because like you said
initially he's like to fund the places
wrong and now he's embracing it
the left has dramatically changed and i
think there's one really easy
and obvious reason young people who are
authoritarian
and pro-state were growing up
entering the the public left the the
political left
and influencing what was being said and
so now all of the prominent
establishment leftists
had to start falling in line with their
changing audience
so they embrace all that stuff i've seen
some sad stories i'm not going to get
into full details but i know some people
who
i'm not going to get into full details i
know some people who have gone through
severe depression i mean
you you live with these people you're
friends with them for for 10 years
you've gone through all these adventures
you've said every awful thing you can
think of because you're trolls on the
internet hackers who believe in free
speech
and then one day all of your friends are
saying you can't say that anymore
everything you've done is wrong and
we're going to cancel you unless you
come out in support of us
and then you're thinking yourself like
these people don't believe
in anything we've done they hate who we
are they hate what we've done
what do you do so jank losing his mind
freaking out snapping at me at politicon
yeah he's trapped
he is trapped in that box also
it's frustrating if you're like the
network and you see
all this talent come through your system
and then they can go be
more successful on your own and you're
seeing your numbers drop
but your former employees doing well
dave rubin i've done videos about how
anna and jank have been unbelievably
nasty to dave rubin talking about how
like they never liked him they wanted to
hire his husband and they like
embarrassed him
it's really nasty stuff that you should
never air publicly jimmy dore
the only difference with the jimmy dore
thing is jimmy dore is using
jank's rhetoric more effectively jank's
the big money and politics guy he'll
tell you
if you take five grand as a congressman
from from the nra
then you're corrupt and you want
children to die by firearms
well jenk took 20 million dollars from
jeffrey katzenberg so when jimmy dore
points that out
everything jank has been saying up until
this time
it jimmy has a rhetorical advantage and
it's like yeah you shouldn't put all
your eggs in the money in politics
basket what what we're seeing with the
meltdown of the young turks is it's
exactly what you were saying
it's funny that you have these people
who are all part of the network
in some way and they move on and find
huge success
jimmy dore is still very much saying
what he's always said
he's critical of the establishment he's
critical of democrats
and and glenn greenwald as well i i i
remember
i criticized glenn greenwald because i
thought he was being unfair to cnn
because he did it he was doing this at
this event and he was talking about cnn
and i was like come on like
you know we can rag on the mainstream
media but hold on there a minute
now i look at a lot of things they're
doing and i've got my criticisms of
glenn greenwald absolutely
but i'm impressed that he stuck stuck to
his principles for as long as he did
to the point where he actually leaves
the intercept jan kuger is watching that
he's watching the people that used to
represent
the people that do represent his values
what he actually believes down inside
but he knows he can't do anything
because he's tethered to this contract
here's what i think 20 million who do
you take it from uh jeffrey katzenberg
so he can't just come out and say the
things he wants to say
because he he has contracts he's locked
in place is katzenberg the disney guy
yeah a former disney ceo yeah big
hillary clinton bundlers
imagine you have a contract that's like
you got to do x y and z
and they're like don't worry we're all
about the the left and progresses right
and you're like this works you sign the
deal
then the progressives become
authoritarian crackpot ideologues
and you're looking at former employees
leaving and your ship is sailing and
you're like i literally can't get off
the boat because of the contract i
signed so are they stuck
under like a contract it's an investment
so like the fact that they're not
profitable
like you know you have to you have to
make a return for your investors it's
not like they
bought the young i'm sure they bought a
portion of it you don't give somebody 20
million dollars for no right
zero percent of their company but uh but
you know it's a private company so a lot
of the details
are are hidden but yeah it's it's that
but and what's funny about glenn
greenwald and jimmy dore being anti-jank
is that jank jimmy dore and greenwald
were all a part of the crew that tried
to kick sam harris out of the left years
ago
so like these are like so when you're
saying glenn greenwald was unfair like
not cnn to sam harris yeah
unbelievably unfair jimmy dore too and
jimmy dore like
even though i'm enjoying this like i'm
not a jimmy dore fan and i
i can't stand people in my audience so
hi guys
jimmy dore's the correct leftist jimmy
dore's the good leftist
like let me be 100 clear about something
have you ever heard the uh this this
idea that um
the young turks inspired a police
shooting i've never heard that before
yeah so it's it's the baton rouge one i
won't name the name for the algorithm
purposes
the young turk that inspired them was
jimmy dore
i do remember hearing about this vaguely
and you can find the videos online so
like for me
like it's a battle of the scummy i will
watch it for entertainment but i'm not
i'm not jumping on anything i like jimmy
dore for one reason
he's he'll talk to you he'll be straight
about it so he has his opinions
he makes his videos he talks about what
we always want to talk about i disagree
with him on a decent amount
but i know that i can message him and
he'll he's like a real human being
and so i i know a lot of people ian and
i have differing opinions
but if we can actually talk and you'll
be honest and in your
conversations like real people then i'm
cool with that like
i i could hang out with a communist so
long as they were totally honest about
what communism was and meant
just don't lie to me and be real and
i'll be like well maybe we shouldn't
maybe we won't be friends
but i can have a polite conversation and
be like that's cool you know
but my thing is is that if i speculated
terribly on a story and that turned out
to be false
and that inspired somebody to kill three
cops i would at least acknowledge it
publicly
you know let me let me explain you know
the
the the young turks rage in in in this
way i i signed a deal with uh
univision's you know in disney fusion's
company it was a two-year contract it
was for a lot of money
and when they started doing bad stuff
and i didn't like it and i didn't want
to play that
ridiculous whoa game they just put me in
golden handcuffs
where they were basically like sit back
and do nothing because there's nothing
you can do and i tried breaking
i i said will you let me out of the
contract they basically said no they
didn't say it outright but they're like
well you know let's revisit the
conversation later and then i'm just
sitting there like i can't do anything
now for me i didn't lose my mind because
i had no obligations to be on camera
saying these things
i literally was just like i'm not gonna
go on camera and say these things
there was an instance where i was doing
a mini doc
on this cop watch group and when i was
talking to some woman about police
brutality
and then i uh it was it was the craziest
thing i brought up
we were just talking and then i
mentioned you know when she said you
know
growing up and being asian in new york
you deal with a lot of police brutality
and i was like yeah i was like my family
absolutely dealt with a lot of the stuff
too because you know i'm part korean and
then she immediately snapped at me and
got really mad and said no you have no
idea what you're talking about take that
back
and i was like but my family did go
through this stuff like we we had bricks
thrown through our window
and then i was just like dude i if you
guys want to finish this shoot
i'm not going to be i'm not going to sit
here and and take a racist you know
insults or anything like that i don't
have to be here i don't want to be
involved in this and i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna be the person on camera
who's in there going like oh i'm so
sorry that i i'm so no i'm not doing it
so they put me in golden handcuffs but i
didn't have to be
you know on camera jank has to host his
show
and so what if he starts saying things
like
the establishment is bad he did say the
democrats lie all the time i can respect
that
but if he starts coming out and saying
you know trump's right about the the
manufacturing base leaving
it's going to hurt the investors they're
going to revolt and they could come
after him for breach of contract you're
hurting the company you are hurting the
investment you owe us
so he has no choice but to sit on this
boat forever
for however long it could be forever
it's an investment it could be forever
he's trapped and he's watching jimmy
dore and glenn greenwald and they're on
the shore waving goodbye as he drifts
further and further out to oblivion
and and the reason jimmy has the
overwhelming advantage in their dispute
is because based on the ideological
parameters that jank has set out
jimmy's right like force the vote for
medicare for all
basically like right i've disputed the
polling around medicare for all multiple
times but that doesn't matter
they all theoretically believe that
everybody's in support of medicare for
all and now is the time to do it
jimmy dore was a hundred percent right
in that progressive
sphere which is why jank lost yeah
publicly in the pr battle for that i
mean i think the young turks are not
long for this
political landscape to be equally honest
and anna did black
like that was an attempted black yeah
well explain that what was that so
she so what what ended up happening is
they were going jimmy was hitting the
young turks for a long time
and i've over forced the vote by name
since like
november december whenever he started
let's let's start from that part
basically there were progressives who
said the the squad and progressive
members of congress should withhold
their support for nancy pelosi
unless pelosi agrees to have a floor
vote on medicare for all yeah
the young turks were like no don't do it
don't help republicans
and they would make up that there was a
scenario where they could make a
republican speaker
which by the way being a speaker without
a majority is meaningless anyway so even
if that wasn't a lie which it was
jank was lying about that it wouldn't
mean anything so
jimmy was calling that out because he
was a big advocate of it and it seemed
like
jank was jealous that like jimmy thought
of it or maybe he was trying to
win or trying to preserve relationships
with the squad
or something like that um over time
that led into uh jimmy attacking jank as
a televangelist because you get 20
million dollars from katzenberg but
you're out there every day like i need
money the funniest email by far
and i'm on the young turks email list so
i saw it is where they said we'll get
you 2 000
stimulus checks if you give us money
the young turks will pressure people in
the democratic party to get you stimulus
checks
wow yeah it's it jenks fundraising is
really greasy and televangelisty
so jimmy's been slamming him over and
over again and again the rhetorical
advantage because the money and politics
argument
according to jank's own logic jimmy's
right
so anna kasparian pops into jimmy dore's
dms
and she runs down this thing she's like
i've been letting you
talk like non-stop about me and tyt
and that's gonna end i'm gonna bring up
this time that you uh like harass me or
apologize
and she names like one instance where he
apologized in there not like alludes to
it
and then she says one time you um said
that you like my jeans and you wanted to
buy a pair for my wife
right for his wife yeah for jimmy's wife
so
jimmy like if you get that message you
have to come out publicly
because if jimmy stopped talking about
the young turks even if it was for a
week
anna could have said look i messaged him
this he hasn't talked about us for a
week
therefore he knows it's true therefore
he's a scumbag so it's a total setup
so jimmy comes out and tells the story
turns out jimmy dore actually told the
story
months earlier oh bump the mic jimmy
told the story months earlier the same
exact story that he told now
without naming anna so like anna tried
to blackmail him in order to get him to
stop and jimmy was criticizing her on
policy her and jank on policy
and she tried to dig up this thing that
he apologized for it was not that big of
a deal
i don't know you know you could listen
to the videos jimmy has it just
that that whole stuff gets a little bit
too in the weeds of like drama between
personalities it shows how nasty the
young turks are
that something that she jimmy apologized
for anna accepted the apology
seven years passed by jimmy has
criticisms of the young turks
as a network and their policy positions
and then they're like oh yeah
shut up or we're going to me to you so
that right so this is where i think
in the in the greater context for those
that probably if you don't care about
the young turks and i mentioned a lot of
people
i'm not saying no one cares about the
youngsters i'm saying probably people
watch us or like i don't watch them
i do it's it's indicative of what's
happening to the mainstream left
messaging
the young turks big powerful prominent
they were like one of the first
they're on youtube tv they have their
own channel and i don't think they'll
last
long because you can't look you know he
got booted from the justice democrats
you can't please this crowd i mean we
just did a
was a segment about how the the black
lives matter activists got boston pride
shut down
you cannot have allegiance to group of
people who will just gut you and
and eviscerate you at a moment's notice
or without even a moment's notice
so the young turks are continually
embracing
nonsensical policy positions notably
like don't push a vote for medicare for
all
i was 100 in favor of the force the vote
not that i thought it could pass but
jimmy said i want to know who opposes it
let the democrats say to their
constituents what they really believe
and i'm like yes
i thought it was hilarious how many
democrats come out and they're like we
absolutely support bernie
and they know their actual core
constituency are moderate and don't want
it
so when it comes to the vote they're
going to be like no
so this is where i had the in in
jimmy logic it works this is where i had
the flaw is because
it's really easy to vote yes on a bill
that you know for a fact it's not going
to pass anyway
so you wouldn't have really gotten a
good assessment of who's in favor who is
opposing it perfect example of this
barack obama votes against raising the
debt ceiling as a senator
now when he's president and the
republicans are threatening to actually
do that
he had to come out and say look i was
grandstanding like that's what you do
when you know a bill is going to pass
for sure
and you think you can grandstand in
voting the opposite way that that's what
you do for political points
but think about the midterms
when primaries happen and they can say
here's them saying yes or no
make them put their money where their
mouth is i want honesty in politics
so if these people are like i'm gonna
lie for votes
and then when it comes to actually
voting they have to make a choice a hard
choice
none of this wish you wash ebs then when
the primary and the midterms come up
there's going to be a video over and
over again of them them saying yay or
nay
or so i i i agree force the vote no i i
i think it fits perfectly if you're in
that camp um but you could also vote
present remember
that's right and then what happens is as
jimmy was stating you get to
uh in the primary say they refused to
support medicare for all they are not
progressive
let that be known the p look i don't
agree with
with most of what these democrats want
but i i do agree the constituents have a
right to know what they actually will do
i don't want under this
i'll just do whatever the whims and
tides of the day are going to be
this came up before man it shouldn't be
like i'm going to trust this person to
do what they said they're going to do it
should be a smart contract built into
their job
they say they're going to do it when
they're running and then they're bound
and it happens automatically whether
they
they don't even get to choose their
issues with that though like what if
they get in and then get
handed a classified document they go oh
wow too bad
i would be i would be fast tell the
people tell the american people they got
a document tell
expose it yup that's true i would be
fascinated if you had them all on record
to see what would actually happen in the
primaries because jimmy's theory of
politics
is that if you vote no on medicare for
all you're losing in the primary
i don't think that's gonna actually pull
out in the
like in the correct way like joe manchin
if he voted i know he's in the senate
but if he voted yes on medicare for all
like he'll probably win his primary but
he's losing to the republican
like he has triangulated his way into
that senate seat that should be a
republican senate seat
and he's the most popular politician in
west virginia history by the way
as a democrat who is joe manchin oh geez
everybody doesn't know people don't like
him but the democrats would not have
that their place in the senate right now
if not for him yep thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you